hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
continuing our coverage of the 2020
us chess championships being held
remotely so wherever these
individuals want to play from day one
yesterday was exciting
they played three rounds sitting atop of
the leaderboard as wesley so he won
all three of his games he's gonna be
playing the black pieces today i thought
what better way to kick off today than
watch him play in round four so he's
gonna be playing the black pieces
his opponent sam shanklin playing the
white pieces he had two draws
and a loss yesterday so looking to get
his first
victory here with the white pieces but
these are
teammates from the chess olympiad know
each other extremely well
so let's go ahead and get into the
action sam starts with
d4 knight f6 c4
e6 and then after knight c3 we get into
the nemzo indian defense we don't see
this all too often so it is
always nice when we do get to
most of the time white doesn't like
playing this because it gives so many
chances for black
the bishop can take here on c3 double up
the pawns
on the c file just something white
usually doesn't want to play
and then sam continues with f3 now the
main line
is e3 so maybe he was okay with this
because he had some additional
preparation going into it
i wasn't sure with 25 minutes on the
clock that each player has
if wesley so would be as prepared
obviously wes also a much higher rated
player
so sometimes you have to think outside
the box against those type of players so
f3 is the play here
and then after d5 you can continue
down the path of e3 which is more the
main line but secondary is to play
a3 and then after the bishop takes which
common themes and
common theme in the nemzo indian is
after the pawn takes here
uh then pawn c5 pawn takes on d5
knight takes on uh d5 putting a lot of
pressure on the c3 square which is
undefended as well as the pawn here on
d4 almost forcing white to play pawn
takes here on
c5 and then after queen two a5
putting pressure both from the queen and
the knight here on
c3 we see the move e4
and i think this is an interesting spot
for a lots of people because
you have this square here on c3 it's not
defended at all
you have two pieces that can attack this
you have the immediate check here with
queen takes here on c3 so
who cares about my knight being attacked
but you can also just take with your
knight here on c3 it's defended by
the queen here this is attacking the
queen here on
uh d1 as soon as it moves it's a
discovered attack but actually
this would be a bad move knight takes
here on
c3 then you see queen to d2 now the
knights pin down to the queen
it can take it as soon as the bishop
comes here to b2 on the next move so you
could see
knight to c6 here uh bishop to
b2 now the knight can move and only
because
it's it was pinned but the knight here
on c6 is defending the queen
but now after the queen takes the knight
takes here bishop takes here on
g7 the rook moves bishop back here to
f6 and you can see both the knights here
on the a file
not exactly where they want to be you
have
whites with a much better setup here
up in material here
all in all not a spot that wesley so
wants to be and even if he takes with
his queen doesn't have to take with his
knight for it to be a mistake it would
still be bad if he takes with his queen
here on
c3 because bishop to d2 the queen is
forced to move here
if he takes on c5 that's even worse
because you you may look and say okay
where does the queen move here but queen
to c5
loses to rook to c1 and there's the
queen pretty much has to fall you could
come back here to
uh c7 which doesn't but you could just
take here on c1
and just give up the queen but if you
move something like d6 as an example you
can see already
rook takes here on c8 and then do you
want to give up your queen now or
do you just want to move your king and
just give up more material either way
it's going to lose you could also
try uh queen 2 e5 that's another way to
escape here
but then white's just going to continue
to attack and so you could play
knight 2 e2 setting up bishop to
c3 here
the knight's under attack from the pawn
on e4 so it comes back to e7 black's
definitely in
a retreat mode bishop to c3 but i can't
get anything going
on while white's just continuing to push
up the board here
and this is a lot of pressure that
wesley snow so does not want
to be under so in this position right
here west is so correctly
which i think a lot of people would
incorrectly play but he plays knight
to e7 now bishop to
e3 castle on the king side queen to
b3 then the queen comes back here to c7
now usually what happens in the nimzo
indian
is that white is up material
and you can see right here that white
has seven pawns to the six pawns of
black but there is the
uh double isolated pawns here on
uh the c file it's gonna be very
difficult for black to hold or for white
to hold on to both of these and so
eventually
black is usually able to capture that
material and then black should have
a good in game
now we see bishop 2 b5 just get involved
into the action
wants to get the night out so you can
castle on the king side
if he wants to doesn't have to castle
for sure
but knight to e2 here bishop to e6 just
moving the pawn up to e5 so the bishop
could come to the center of the board
and attack the queen
instead of moving the queen decides you
could just push up forward here with
c4 knight to uh
c6 knight here to c3
knight to a5 it could always take here
but it doesn't really do too much
because then the knight's just gonna
take here it's exactly the position that
black has but all of a sudden white
doesn't have the bishop hair
that is the one thing that white has
going for him
and so sam needs to take advantage of
that at some point he needs to open up
the board really use
that bishop pair so decides to play
knight to c3
knight to a5 attacking the queen and
then
queen to b4 knight to c6
putting more pressure on the queen and
then what i think is
kind of first move that kind of had my
head scratching
is this queen to a four
it almost feels like the queen is
trapping itself
could it just come back to b2 it can't
come to b3 because it's attacked by the
knight here but
b2 makes a lot of sense still on this
dark square diagonal
protecting the knight right here still
protecting the bishop has the pawn and
the queen defending that but queen to a4
and then wesley so starts to attack here
with pawn
to a6 and then the bishop takes here we
do see
the knight take on c4 so maybe he
thought the knight would come back here
and take on c6 but takes here on
c4 bishop takes on b7
and then knight two e three and after
the bishop takes then we see
queen two c five
now knight two d5 and at this spot uh
wesley so
has gone up a ton of material if you're
watching these games
i usually watch on chess 24 but they
will go through some of the variations
that each player can play and then
they'll give a score
and in this position it said wesley so
would
play knight to c2 and he would be
negative four which means black is up
four uh points in material uh which is
which is extremely massive and so we're
just kind of waiting for wesley to do
that because
it seemed like he'd calculated all of
this from five or six moves ago
he took a long time and eventually
played knight takes here
on g2 which is definitely surprising
because
that pretty much put it at equal odds
for both players so
sam pretty quickly then played king 2f1
as
things are back to normal here a lot of
the threat is gone
so knight comes back to f4 queen up here
to
c6 queen to a5
and then after things have gone
extremely well for white
has a chance to get back in it he makes
the fatal mistake and plays
rook to d1
because i just don't think he really
calculated he's eyeing up here
this d5 square which makes a lot of
sense
bishop takes here on d5 pawn takes here
on d5
what i don't think he realized is that
black was no longer going to
attack this square here on d5 instead
wesley so is going to play
queen to a3
attacking the square here on f3
and you can see that's not going to go
well at all that's going to end in a
very quick
checkmate so sam really has to
protect the pawn the only way to do that
is to play d6 that's exactly what he
does
but then queen two b2 and now the threat
is the queen coming over here to
g2 and there's no way to really stop
that so
yeah you can bring your queen down here
to e4 that's fine but queen g2
king over here e1 you're going to lose
your rook here on h1
check king 2 d2 you can see stuff
starting to fall apart here gobbling up
material
queen takes here on h2 then all of a
sudden you have wesley so one of the
best players in the world with
an active queen a knight here on an
outpost that can start to get involved
into the action a rook here that
any time could take the bishop on a8 but
it can also swing into the action
start to attack the king here things are
not going to go well with an exposed
king like this knight to e2 getting
involved check
all of a sudden knight 2 d4 still a
great outpost here for the knight
uh d7 sure pushing up but you're never
gonna have a chance to do anything with
the promotion there
queen two a two and then a couple moves
later we do
have the end of the game and the
simulations were running
and it was showing that this was gonna
be mate
and not too many moves uh you know eight
or nine moves to depending on
uh where white ends up going so at the
end uh sam
does decide to resign wesley so wins not
only did he win
round four ended up winning round five
as well now did draw
game number six it almost seemed like he
was going to go back-to-back days
winning every single game but he sits
atop
of the leaderboard with five and a half
points
out of a total of six so it definitely
seems like he is
steamrolling the competition here so
we'll see if he can continue
but congratulations to him on a great
win always nice when you're playing the
black pieces
and even when you make a big mistake you
can still
come back and get the victory that's
exactly what he did
thank you guys so much for watching
hopefully you enjoyed
this video hopefully you're enjoying the
series as well and i'll see you tomorrow
for a game
from round seven eight or nine thanks
for watching bye
you